[Applaudissements]
mais déchiré à billets à 7 sur 7
et alors il paraît que j'avais fait très
bien ce que gagnent et se sait ce que ça
me prend je suis un insoumis
voilà ses salutations et et ça bien sûr
c'était ça bon on a bien fait le terreau
beau dire n'importe quoi aux jeunes
vous avez réussi à faire exploser gilles
verdez viva commentaire c'est minable
c'est pas l'argent
il est payé pour sa mémoire
[Applaudissements]
et ça se passait au bio ou non la
dernière direct ah non
enfin avant de partir de femmes du foot
a provoqué alors rappelons les faits
suivants
ben c'est sûr j'ai encore des réflexions
de la 2 17 heures non parce que petites
minutes emploi bons plans influent un
cost de foot heures mais c'est sais pas
je sais ce qu'on va faire mesdames et
messieurs ça n'arrive jamais mais là là
je ne maîtrise plus voilà je le dis
humblement je pourrais faire croire que
tout ceci est voulue mais dont j'ai ici
la baronne qui a pété les plombs chez
l'ornithorynque ce qui est complètement
à plat
j'ai le chevelu qui ont peu plus j'ai
david luiz qui n'arrête pas de se mettre
à dos je remets tout ça à plat
je reviens dans quelques instants suite
de bertrand chez nous
[Applaudissements]
il écrit c'est du jeu